the historic Cathedral city of st.
Albans in hartfordshire named after
Britain's first Christian martyr known
for its Roman ruins medieval clock tower
and artisan shops this is a classic
commuter town trains take just 20
minutes to London with good local
schools and a house prices to match 63%
of people here back to remain and the
Lib Dems are quietly confident that this
is a seat they can take from the
Conservatives the remain sign in st.
Albans is very very strong so I think
they will the Conservatives will
struggle with their one sided brexit
plans I took a real liking to Daisy
Cooper yeah the Lib Dems I've got a
feeling that the current MP and main is
very out of touch with the people in st.
Albans I think it would definitely go
Lib Dem here I'm certainly I I must
admit I because of the experience of the
referendum I'm one of those that's quite
jaded about thinking does my vote
actually matter
it's brexit the most important thing to
you when you vote it could well be if it
becomes a vote for this party and you
will avoid brexit then yes it would
become number one and I think st. Albans
as a majority remain a town will say
exactly the same thing as a whole just
won't agree for getting any thought to
how you might be voting the Lib Dems are
already in campaign mode out in force in
Saint Peter's Ward where 74 percent of
people voted remain in the referendum
the local candidate Daisy Cooper came
second at the 2017 election with a 14
percent increase in vote chan there's a
lot of conservative remainders who are
viscerally angry about what's happened
to the Conservative Party about the fact
that it's become a vote leave party and
basically they don't feel represented by
the Conservative Party don't feel
represented by the opposition that it
feel represented by their local MP are
you confident you're gonna win here
we're very hopeful so we've had some
really good results this year in the
local elections we took control of the
council we've got 40 percent share of
the vote in the European Parliament
elections so we're hopeful that people
who are already voting for us and who
have already voted for us twice this
year will continue to vote for us again
at the German
section is called I'm interested to
think a bit more about the Lib Dem
strategy more broadly I mean where would
you put the Lib Dems on the political
scale and meaning us into that party you
center-right party where'd you put well
historically I would say that we've
always been a sort of socially liberal
party so sort of slightly center-left
and but I'm not sure that that
left-right the dynamic makes sense
anymore to a lot of people there is this
shift going on from left and right to a
sense of open and closed values and I
think that hearings and Albans and
people who are former conservative and
Labour voters see the Lib Dems as their
natural home now we are internationalist
we are environmentalists we're
pro-business we're Pro social justice
and they say to ask that they share our
values I mean do you think that really
if the opportunity for the Lib Dems is
to take votes from the Conservatives in
places like st. Albans you actually need
to be positioning yourself more as the
center-right party no I'm not sure that
that's correct the factors new the Lib
Dems have a set of values we are
liberals and other people are realising
that they share our liberal values so I
don't think that we need to be shifting
where we are at all as a party we know
that precisely where we are people are
coming to vote for us the Conservatives
have helped an Auburn since 2005 but the
6,000 vote majority is looking
vulnerable Alec Campbell was the leader
of st. Albans council until he lost her
seat to the Lib Dems earlier this year
he wants to move the political
conversation on from brexit I think
we've got the challenges of breaks it's
and what's happening nationally and I
think that is equating is locally so
what we want to do is really focus on
our record of achievement in government
in terms of record employment levels
increases a increase in NHS funding and
increase in police numbers but that's
actually quite difficult sometimes to
get beyond that because grexit is the
big issue at the moment
how optimistic or not are you ahead of a
potential general election I'm always
optimistic but I think the the challenge
is is that when is the election going to
be because I think if it was now I think
we would have a lot of difficulty or
would have a lot of difficulty because
of the uncertainty of a brexit
nationally and the you know difficulty
of the government's got in the fact that
we've chemical is split between tea
the remain group and the leave creeping
in the Conservative Party and the
moderate group include the more the more
break set minded group so you know I
think at the moment we would have a real
big challenge we need to recognize that
they are part of the party that really
represents many of the people in st.
Albans does it worry a little bit and
that they've the way they've been
treated well it does and but I'm hoping
that we can actually come to some
reconciliation pretty soon and get them
back into we saw the whip and move
forward it were worried at the apparent
strategy by Boris Johnson to really
target those bricks at supporting seats
in the north could actually mean that
the Conservative Party losers six lights
and ovens
I think that that is a big concern for
me and the Association as well I think
that you know what we want to do we
think a conservative message works in
st. Albans and it should work in Saint
Albans and you know what we don't want
to do is to actually you know try and
win pick up seats and in the north which
I think actually would be very difficult
to do and the expensive seats down here
Forest Johnson's election strategy is to
mop up the leave boat and brexit backing
marginals while hoping the remain vote
is split between labor and the Lib Dems
but the problem is and marginal sites
that opens the remain vote isn't split
if they lose ground in areas like this
than the path to a majority was even
more difficult the Lib Dems anti brexit
position is playing well in some Albans
but it could hold them back in other
parts of the country the Liberal
Democrats if they're going to win and
win win big and recover as a party
because there are very very small minor
party today in terms of parliamentary
representation they need centrist voters
many of whom would identify a
center-right and the move towards
revocation is in my opinion unhelpful
briggsie is a is a good starting point
for the Liberal Democrats it gives them
a clear message and cut through that
they've lacked for a decade and however
it's not nearly enough for them to
campaign as a single issue party that's
not how voters votes the coming election
yes it's an election that has been
brought about by the convulsions of
Briggs
but actually it Briggs isn't going to be
the only question of the election
domestic issues matter in May mattered
in 2017 they mattered in 2015 and
they'll matter again in 2019 as the Lib
Dems gather for their annual conference
this weekend the leader Joe Swenson says
she wants to be Prime Minister that may
be a little ambitious but thanks to six
fights and opens the resurgent party
could still have a big say in the
outcome of the next general election
[Applause]